[Music]  do not cry little fish I have returned  and with help oh thank you seaman you  really think you can have my mom get to  heaven it's sea man and yes I do  this child has incredible powers all  right if you get my mom into heaven I  will give you three million dollars and  some jewelry just touch my little gay  flipper and we should be magically  transported to help her touching the gay  fishes flipper semen and his sidekick  are transported to Valhalla where  another fish rides a unicorn I'm here  mama it's me we're gonna get you to  heaven mama just hold on this kid's  gonna help us we should put this whole  event on a gold disc and send it into  space so that aliens can see it yeah but  wait what the [ __ ] is that supposed to  mean  get the stick of truth free with  purchase pre-order now for Towelie bonus  content  [Music]